das langweilige Heißgetränk kalt zu
servieren und mit bubbles zu pimpen war
revolutionär der Riesenhype ging um die
ganze Welt so wie Sebastian er reist
nach Taiwan wo das Trendgetränk erfunden
wurde
[Musik]
Sebastian liege reißt nach Taiwan hier
wurde das Teegetränk vor über 30 Jahren
entwickelt
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen die Geburtsstätte
des Bubble Tees und wie die Original
Bubble Tea schmeckt und gemacht wird das
schaue ich mir jetzt mal an
das große Konzerthaus von Taipei hier
trifft Sebastian lege Frau lincio Heu
sie hat den Bubble Tea erfunden weil sie
traditionellen
hallo
ich habe eine teilvanesische
Teezeremonie für dich vorbereitet
die gehört dem Taiwan seit Jahrtausenden
zum Kulturgut er wird nach einem ganz
speziellen Ritual zubereitet und
getrunken
[Musik]
vor dem Trinken soll Sebastian lege erst
einmal riechen damit er alle Aromen des
Tees wahrnimmt
[Musik]
das war verdammt lecker so aromatisch
bei so wenig habe ich noch nie getrunken
vorher in den 1980er Jahren
interessieren sich immer weniger Junge
taiwanesinnen und Taiwanesen für Tee
damals will Frau Linn das Tee trinken
[Musik]
sie probiert neue Teegetränke aus und
setzt 1988 auf Schwarztee mit Eiswürfeln
der Anfang von Bubble Tea
den heißen
brachte viele junge Leute unsere
Teekultur wieder näher
für die süße gibt Frau Linn einen
kleinen Schluck Zuckersirup in den Tee
dazu Milchpulver das nimmt dem kalten
Tedi
hoffentlich mache ich keinen Fehler den
gibt's Ärger vom Chef die wichtigste
Idee von Frau Linn ist so einfach wie
genial in den kalten Tee gibt sie
Kügelchen aus tapioka-stärke die Bubbles
im Team aus traditionellem kännchen-tee
wird ein cooles spaßgetränk mit
Strohhalm aus dem Becher to go
[Musik]
seitdem ich 1984 ins Teegeschäft
eingestiegen bin habe ich eine Menge
über Tee gelernt
Tee mit Milch habe ich schon immer
gemocht na sind und in meiner Kindheit
habe ich Tapioka Desserts geliebt die
ganze Schulzeit hindurch
als ich dann mein Geschäft gegründet
habe habe ich einfach meine
Lieblingszutaten kombiniert
und weil es bei uns im Sommer so heiß
ist habe ich das Ganze kalt serviert und
so ist dann der Bubble Tea entstanden
Frau Linn ist in Taiwan heute eine
berühmte Frau sie hat das Tee trinken
für junge Leute gerettet und
gleichzeitig eine Lawine losgetreten
Bubble Tea hat sich in allen Varianten
selbstständig gemacht wir machen die
nämlich Bubble Team mit Früchten
absolute Spezialität und dafür ist er
berühmt
das sieht aus wie ein Obstsalat
die Nachahmer haben Frau Linz Rezept
verstanden Zucker und Kügelchen
und sie haben Kreationen mit mehr Zucker
und noch mehr Kügelchen auf den Markt
gebracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow um süß Karamellschicht unten
ungesüßter Tee
oben drauf Frischkäse unten kalter Tee
hier
und das ist warm das ist so Wahnsinns
Kreation
Bubble Tea wird weltweit ständig
verändert bunter süßer schneller Frucht
bubbles statt Tapioka ein riesiger Berg
an wegwerfbechern bleibt zurück
und sogar ertrinken das scheint hier
wirklich ein großes Ding zu sein
so viele Perlen an jeder Ecke und genau
hier werden die hergestellt kommen Sie
mit
die Perlen im ursprünglichen Bubble Tee
bestehen aus tavioka eine
geschmacksneutrale Stärke aus der
Maniokwurzel in Asien ein traditionelles
Bindemittel in der Fabrik in Taipeh
mischt Sebastian lege braunen Zucker mit
Tapioka Stärke es entstehen die dunklen
Perlen für Bubble Tea
drehen wir einfach den hier
und nur den Rotation ganz einfach das
ist die Mischung hier oben gemacht wurde
und daraus werden die Perlen genialer
Trick nach dem Verpacken sind die
Tapioka-Perlen jahrelang haltbar sie
machen Bubble die zu einem der
berühmtesten Exportprodukte von Taiwan
weltweit ist Bubble Tea weiter auf dem
Vormarsch in den nächsten Jahren soll
der Umsatz auf mehr als 7 Milliarden
US-Dollar ansteigen
Frau Linz Erfindungen hat Tee wieder
populär gemacht mit unerwünschten
Nebenwirkungen auf der ganzen Welt
[Musik]
auf der ältere Kinder ist Bubble Tea
wirklich nicht der geeignete
Durstlöscher denn er enthält viel Zucker
künstliche Aromen und Farbstoffe und
dann wirklich noch ein bisschen Tee
Extrakt in der Regel und keinen
richtigen Tee dafür bezahle ich aber
viel Geld und bekomme am Ende sehr viele
Kalorien
eine Aufgabe für Sebastian lege
entwickle die mit viel Geschmack und
gesunden Zutaten
herzlich willkommen in meiner Bubble Tea
Fabrik ich habe mir gedacht ich mache
das mal in gesund also ich glaube ich
mache auf alle Fälle sowas wie
Karotte und Ingwer Tomate und Gurke
vielleicht auch wirklich auf die Gemüse
Ebene das zu machen ich will irgendwas
kreieren wo die Leute sagen ja das
schmeckt sehr interessant nicht so süß
wie Bubble Tea aber eine tolle
Alternative der Produktentwickler setzt
auf kalorienarme alginatperlen der
Zusatzstoff wird aus Algen gewonnen in
einem calciumbad gelieren die
alginatkugeln Außen gefüllt sind sie mit
Saft im Mund können die saftkugeln dann
lustig platzen
originat Calcium das sind unsere beiden
Stoffe die miteinander reagieren und
hier entstehen die kleinen Tropfen
in die calciumflüssigkeit gelieren außen
rum und fertig sind meine bubbles passt
die Rezeptur nicht kommt der Tropfen
rein und verschwindet im Wasser
der erste Testlauf Sebastian lege ist
mit dem Resultat schon ganz zufrieden
[Musik]
hier sind meine kleinen bubbles
du babbeln auch schon voll ja die sind
schon gar nicht schlecht aber noch viel
zu klein und der Basis Tee fehlt mir
auch noch ich habe hier ungesüßten Tee
dann nehme ich noch ein bisschen
Karottensaft Karotte in Spirulina das
wäre jetzt gar nicht so schlecht oder
ja das schmeckt noch nicht so richtig
gut die Babbel sind noch viel zu klein
ich muss hier noch ein bisschen tüfteln
und dann geht's raus auf die Straße und
dann frage ich die Leute mal was Sie von
meiner neuen alternative so halten Tage
lange Tüftelei für Produktentwickler
Sebastian lege ist das Alltag er
arbeitet am besten möglichen Geschmack
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
am Düsseldorfer Rheinufer will Sebastian
lege seinen Bubble Tea testen er hat
eine richtig gesunde Alternative im
besser Esser mobil
herzlich Willkommen an meinem Bubble Tea
stand ich habe mir gedacht das ganze
mache ich jetzt mal in komplett
natürlich natürliche bubbles natürliche
Tees mit weniger Zucker und ich bin
gespannt ob die Leute mit den abkaufen
die ersten Düsseldorferinnen und
Düsseldorfer treten an zur großen
gesunden Bubble Tea Verkostung
[Musik]
ist sehr gut sehr gut ja nicht schlecht
nicht zu süß mir schmeckt gut der Tee
ist weniger süß
finde ich gut also schmeckt mir bei den
bubbles sind die Testerinnen und Tester
die Bubbles haben nicht so die normale
Festigkeit
natürlich und ohne raffiniertem Zucker
[Gelächter]
was war das eine coole Verkostung und
die Leute mögen das gar nicht so süß wie
der Verkauf wird die natürliche Variante
hat ihn richtig gut geschmeckt ich
glaube ich habe eine Geschäftsidee der
Bubble trägt zeigt das auch gesunde und
vermeintlich uncoole Lebensmittel wieder
gut ankommen wenn Sie Spaß machen
höchste Zeit dass auch die Industrie
endlich mal Produkte erfindet auf die
die Verbraucher wirklich warten
[Musik]